think but when uh a group of people was
appointed to look into English Cricket
it was terribly important that they were
seen to be utterly fair and as it
happens I got nothing against Cindy bets
at all who were headed the the
commissioner whatever you call it of
course I have like I've never met her
but she is an activist of black lives
matter and I think a one or two or three
of her colleagues in this and it makes
you think that they may have come with
an agenda with an ax to grind that may
be unfair but nonetheless I think it's
worth pointing out and I do think that
in this situation one needed to pick a
group that were able to look at it in an
absolutely even-handed way because I
still don't believe I've talked to a lot
of people involved in cricket and they
don't recognize or that or they don't
think this report represents the game
they played